[Music]
vinney is with us in tampa
all right is it vinnie did i say that
correctly
yes dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
all right so i recently started working
on the baby steps and i'm almost at the
baby step two but i'm trying to pay off
my personal loans and credit cards
but uh here's the thing so
more than half of my income goes into
paying off the minimum minimum payments
and then the
uh personal expenses and rent and stuff
you know
so i'm trying to pay off my debt as soon
as possible but it's like
the minimum payments are eating off my
income
so
i don't know i'm all confused now what's
your income
about
6 500 a month
okay and um how much debt do you have
uh
40 000 around 40 000
on
what uh on personal loans and credit
card debt
okay no no car payment
no i'm my my i don't have a car with me
i've made it quarter recently so i don't
have it anymore and your take-home pay
is 6 500.
yeah so you're taking home 78 000 a year
and you got 40 000 in debt there should
be some margin here
to attack this debt
so the question is where's all the money
going
i'm making the minimum payments that
that's what eating up my
my
my income you know like i'm trying to
cut down my personal expenses but it's
just not happening
but your minimum payments aren't three
thousand dollars a month
are they
they are they are yeah you must have
short terms on this debt
yes exactly you got like a debt that's a
one year or a two year debt or did you
get into payday lending or something or
what'd you get into here yeah
2.5 years i was unemployed for a
while and uh i had to take some personal
loans
in
yeah yeah you got a short term
okay
yeah so the good news is if you pay the
minimum payments you're gonna be done in
two and a half years with a lot of them
so anything extra you can put on there
is gonna accelerate that
so you should be out of debt in under
two years
okay by just paying a little extra
beyond your minimum payments does that
sound right
yeah it makes sense but when i try to
calculate my uh the debt and my income
i'm i see that it's half of my entire
income for a year so i'm i'm trying to
get that done in a year but it's not
happening so
it's so i just have to make those
minimum payments for two years and get
that now i'm saying i'm saying it's
somewhere between there it's not the
it's not the minimum payments it's more
than the minimum payments but your
minimum payments are so high
that they're not
um
that they are because they're on a short
term
and that's jamming it up and that's
forcing the payment size up to in order
to pay it off in two and a half years on
a regular amortization
so yeah you're you're going to pay the
minimum payments plus a little and
that's going to get you out in under two
and a half years but you're probably not
going to make it in one year
you could but you're really going to
have to tighten up expenses even further
than you figured out a way to do yet so
make sure you're doing a written budget
on every dollar
and uh make sure you've really analyzed
how much you're eating out really
analyzed how much you're spending on any
kind of luxury item of any kind and the
other thing you can do is look at
picking up a side hustle yeah there's
only two ways to create margin you're
either gonna have to get more income or
shave down your expenses and i would do
both if i was in your shoes so i'm
looking at every side job i can take if
you can do overtime do that you're gonna
have to sacrifice if you want to see
this stuff gone and on the budget side
like dave saying i'm going through every
single line item and i'm doing an audit
can i shave this down am i paying too
much for this i'm going to work on all
my insurance rates make sure i'm not
overpaying on premiums i'm going to cut
down eating out and once you do that
you're going to give yourself a raise
and find 500 magically in the couch
cushions of your budget
the other thing you can make sure of is
that make sure you have stopped
retirement temporarily
make sure you're not getting a tax
refund if you are that means that you
are having too much withheld and you
need to adjust your withholding so
you're bringing home even more uh you
just keep fine-tuning all of these
little things and i think you're going
to get there i think you're going to get
there faster than you feel like you're
going to get there